we have this from The Daily Mail corrupt
file and system reboot caused all U.S
flights to be grounded for the first
time since 9 11. no Tam's system and
backup were both infected with corrupt
file as Pilots slam ridiculous decision
to ground planes I don't believe these
people I almost feel like when you get
AOC coming out calling for a green New
Deal saying we got to get rid of planes
and farting cows that when these people
ground every single plane in the country
and maybe it's political or ideological
now I don't know anything about that for
sure but I can't tell you this the FAA
verified on Twitter tweeted out cleared
update number two for all stakeholders
the FAA is still working to fully
restore blah blah you get the point I
noticed the word stakeholders yes I know
some people mention that stakeholders
been used in certain contexts like this
for some time but in 2021 October the
FAA announced they'd be changing their
language to be more inclusive they then
start talking about how their
stakeholders blah blah blah
the world economic forum is pushing
what's called stakeholder capitalism the
idea is a shareholder is represented by
those who own shares State capitalism is
represented by the state and stakeholder
is better because it's everyone the
environment the neighbors the people
Downstream the people Upstream the
people on the other side of the planet
yeah it basically sounds like communism
oh 100 basically sounds like State
capitalism except for the planet instead
of an individual state where they're
basically like they they actually say
this on the is there's a website called
Advanced ESG and they're like basically
saying that with a guiding force
stakeholder capitalism blah blah blah
this is why it's important because I
want to show you this one I know they're
different stories I talked about this
this morning but M.I.A the musician
mentioned that she got booted from a
concert the email says we have not take
the kicker out they say your tweets were
bad we have not taken this decision
lightly but we must consider the wider
risk risks to the festival and its
stakeholder years there's an important
connection between these stories
the phrase stakeholder did this this
concert that banned M.I.A call all of
their stakeholders doubtful did they
email the people who bought tickets who
are stakeholders do they even Define who
the stakeholders are exactly they are
what they're basically saying is we're
doing this for you we're doing all of
this for you so in the FAA is coming out
saying all the planes are shut down
everyone we're all in this together but
you know we're not because they're not
Consulting us they're not asking us what
we want they're telling us what they
want and they're using stakeholder as a
word to make you think you're part of it
but my friends that's like the chickens
thinking they work with me when I own
them the thing about shareholder
capitalism is that it's on contract if
you have a percentage of a company or
shares in a company you have a contract
to verify stakeholder is just it's
subjective like one day I could dump
trash up River and say everyone down
river is a stakeholder in my behavior
because they're all going to be affected
by it but then the next day I could say
no no I put a dam in there or a shifting
mechanism now those people aren't
stakeholders anymore because I changed
the way my system works so you have no
recourse as a stakeholder in those
systems is completely controlled from
the top I I highly warn against it I
think Klaus has taken us down or
attempting to take us down a very
dangerous road Klaus Schwab with his
world economic Forum stakeholder
capitalism and your item it is communism
it's a form of Communism all I know is
Buddha judge is having a bad week I had
a few months he's had all these
disasters happen and crises uh happen
under you know on his watch basically I
mean what it was like the Railroad
Strike and then the the shipping
container issue and wasn't there there
was one other one before this that like
just happened he's like when a vacation
disappeared oh yeah it was like import
um not Puerto Rico
look at me I can't remember I don't know
something like that there's been there's
been like four or five issues con
consecutively that just have you know he
hasn't um been dealing with that great
but that's what happens when you uh
make a diversity higher you hire the gay
guy just because he's gay right I mean
he really had no experience or
um accomplishments to really put him in
this position I don't necessarily think
it was a diversity hyperbooty touch no I
think it's they're trying to tee him up
for a future political career and he
needed something Beyond just being I
guess I guess it's just really I mean
that that that job that position is just
a weird one I don't think but he's but
he says so it's like he doesn't even
qualify as diversity at this point he's
what says sis oh sis right oh says yeah
no that's when when when yeah see I got
you when uh when they were talking about
him like all the activists on Twitter
were like he doesn't count as LGBT
because he's a white man just being gay
isn't enough anymore especially being
white and gay no no that's very low
that's very long ranks now yeah he's not
a diversity hire I guess not you've
proved me wrong do you guys think that
the uh this FAA issue with the um the
computer program is a false flag and or
a computer virus that a foreign country
put in the system some many people spec
calculated my business might have been a
Cyber attack yeah the Biden
Administration said it wasn't I would
lean more towards their intentionally
crippling the economy and this had a
profound impact we were affected by this
we had people who needed to fly out for
work and we had a hiccup that delays us
what y'all need to understand about
economic Warfare let me tell you
something
China and the US they're both at War a
component of that war and a component of
every war is let's go all the way to the
beginning putting food in bellies the
saying goes that soldiers march on their
stomachs if you can't feed your soldiers
you lose the war that is to say you need
to find food and you need to be growing
that food there need to be people who
are working Farms otherwise there's no
war
so for someone like China or Russia or
anyone else at War
shutting down our capability of flight
means all all this economic activity
just ceases and that means our ability
to develop Tech our ability to run our
businesses is diminished simply put it's
very similar to if you were at war with
someone thousands of years ago and you
set fire to all their Farms so they
couldn't feed their soldiers our planes
getting shut down may seem like well we
can't fly and have fun and go travel on
vacation but in reality it means with
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of flights canceled business
is shutting down for days too because
it'll be people trying to catch up I
think when we talk about Insurrection
people say they March into the Capitol
building and stood there that they
destroyed or disrupted the government
maybe in part this is the kind of thing
that's an Insurrection if these were
American citizens that implanted a virus
like shutting down the electrical grid
the transportation system the food
supply though that's real Insurrection
in an economic Warfare State the fact
that they're using the world economic
Forum terminology just says to me like
outright I don't trust them because
these are the same people who are like
we should and be flying on planes planes
are bad but they
they all fly on private jets with their
5 000 Jets at the climate like Summit
exactly they don't want you to have it
because you're a pleb but they should
have it yeah because well that's not
fair well it's bad for our stakeholders
but me flying on a private jet to do the
work that I do to save the world is good
for our stakeholders you see how that
works yeah they they consider that like
you know a benefit for the Earth because
they're so important and they're such
Geniuses that they're going to go solve
it but they need to take their private
jet and and cruise on their private
yachts Mega Yachts you know and it's all
part of the process you have to trust
the process and the science that's right
that's right yeah stakeholder capitalism
is is the future my friend it makes no
sense I don't understand I still don't
understand it it's communism you're not
supposed to understand it it's not
Capital it's used I'll tell you exactly
what it is it is Chinese style communism
if you read their website they say
that stakeholder capitalism takes into
consideration anyone impacted by a
business not just the shareholders and
the customers this allows free market
opportunities to flourish while still
being responsible and that's meaningless
yeah this is this is about the
centralization of power very few people
have a lot of power they want all of it
they want more of it so what better way
to do it than to think of these new
buzzwords that of course amount to
anything and essentially what they're
building up to here some people have
called it the great reset some people
have called it the UN 2030 agenda some
people have called it the new world
order at the end of the day all of it
leads to is the massive centralization
of power for themselves Davos is about
to start next week and their theme for
next week is quote cooperation in a
fragmented world the list of attendees
was released and it's the FBI director
the CEOs of Amazon BlackRock Pfizer The
Gates Foundation the Solaris Network 52
heads of state 600 CEOs are going to be
meeting at one of the highest points in
all of Europe where they of course will
meet privately talk about a lot of
things publicly as well but at the end
of the day this is a list of of just
absolute lunatic criminals coming
together that are going to come together
in a way that benefits them and they're
going to think of more schemes more
buzzwords in order to convince you to go
up your power and authority to them you
know what this makes me think of is the
Bilderberg Group or the the Bilderberg
meetings remember that whatever happened
to those it is
I covered it last year and it was me and
my friend just uh Josh Friedman that
covered it and we were the only two
journalists there wow and you can still
see that coverage
um you know on my YouTube channel but no
one else I thought they like dropped off
and this was like their new gig but it's
still happening well there's there's
private meetings amongst other private
meetings there's smaller groups and
bigger groups and you know you know when
when you have so many powerful people
come together in one room when you have
the FBI director coming and meeting with
the heads of Pfizer there's a lot of
ability there for them to of course hey
say I'm gonna give you this money in
this way you just kind of make sure you
weaponize the intelligence stage to go
after our critics and to think that
that's not happening that these people
aren't colluding together and conspiring
together for their own personal benefit
is absolutely I mean that's the sole
purpose does anybody believe otherwise
truly well when when we look at these
meetings and we look at what these
people say especially yoel Roth Harari
they're coming on and saying there's
going to be you know a time very soon
where people are going to be useless
there's going to be a lot of people that
are going to need to adjust themselves
to live in virtual reality a lot of
individuals who won't have any meeting
who won't have any jobs who will be
absolutely meaningless in our world and
we won't need them so this is what
they're thinking about this is a part of
also their fourth Industrial Revolution
Klaus Schwab likes to talk about this as
well but essentially this is the larger
takeover of our life and our society for
the benefit of the very few you got a
couple names mixed up it's Yuval Noah
Harari yeah
yoel Roth is the Twitter guy
they look very similar by the way
similar names they look extremely sir
thank you for that factor I know he's a
fascinating guy here sapiens the book
and I mean in a way they're talking
about the transhumanist you know
Evolution and how we're we are you know
in a lot of ways we're becoming cyborgs
you know maybe inevitably maybe
um so it I I think it's not like they're
completely wrong about everything in
Pure Evil like they're just trying to
find a way to make things not go to
World War III but I don't agree with
that I think where did you get that
there's a thing called order out of
chaos they sow the chaos in order to
yeah they create the problem in order to
create the solution which benefits them
that's that's their kind of code book
that they've been working from for a
very long time because you look at a lot
of our problems that Humanity deals with
these problems are usually engineered
from a top level and done in a way where
of course people will Galvanize towards
them asking them to please stop or only
when they give up their money or their
rights does it stop and then it never
does stop it's just a larger con game
that people keep playing into
um that's screwing them over yeah I
thought 911 was like that just whip
people up into a frenzy got them all to
go to war in the Middle East for weapons
that didn't exist and then so you think
the next one's aliens or something I
mean the pandemic is a great example too
I mean they they
manufactured this fear you know by the
indoctrination they honestly groom
Society with this big Pharma groom them
and and all of their cohorts but to make
them basically beg for a vaccine to open
back up you know to give them their
lives back what Trump was the one who
who spent the operation worship was all
him they engineered they engineered a
lot of things uh exactly but like but
then they come in with their their
solutions to the problems they create
like if kovid wasn't put on TV and just
blasted everywhere 24 7 for like a year
and a half two years people would not
think anything of it they'd think if
they were getting a cold or like you
know a flu or whatever thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time